okay you might know us I'm in the exact
same place as I was for the last be like
that's because I pretty much just
watched two episodes in a row yeah I
just I am well extra time so I'm
figuring I'd just do them but the same
time so okay
so this one is ah that's why I have the
Wikipedia because I always create the
tiles ah Bato of the Water Tribe which I
don't really know why it's called back
because he doesn't play a major part in
this really it's not really about him
but the title idols um I'll be honest
this is the first episode I've seen so
far that actually did not like uh and
that in no way means Oh avatars going
downhill how could you do this avatar
you're doing so crazy
every show's gonna have shows that you
know you're not gonna like or just
aren't gonna hold up you even the Great
Divide I do like the episode up until
the last 30 seconds um you know but but
this was the first one I was watching I
was like no this seems a lot of things
going on in here not only don't make
sense but I really had a character uh
which was really surprising for me you
know because yeah you can nip big little
things here and there but this seemed
like no that does not seem like you know
something I was properly built up to and
then properly delivered this episode
they come across a member of Sokka and
Katara's tribe I was it was a friend of
her father's um and he says that a
letter is coming in who's gonna that's
gonna show where their father is uh Aang
I guess gets jealous that they're gonna
see their dad or that he's not part of
the Water Tribe techniques I don't know
it's very odd you just know he's upset
about something there um you know maybe
that they have the parents or event one
still alive I don't does not seem like
aim to get jealous over something like
that but so he sort of runs off
coincidentally during the moment when
they say hey would you like to come with
us to see the father and say Oh that'd
be great and he feels heartbroken and
walks out and then they say but we
really should stick with Angus I hate
Valley ate that is so contrived how
often does that happen real life how can
we you know deal with real-life problems
like the show is trying to teach us when
you throw in stuff that doesn't happen
oh I hate those but that that's not the
only thing um so this messenger comes
see Zhang says hey you look like a
waterbender can you get this - you know
Bato it's the map - you know where uh
Sokka and Katara's a father is so he
looks and goes mmm I don't think so when
he crumbles it up and puts it in his
best who the hell is this when again
this is a monk this is you know yeah
it's a kid but he's still a monk and you
know yeah he's gonna make mistakes like
a kid that where did this sudden weird
jealousy come from to go this far to
keep these kids from their father
very weird uh so okay so he gets rid of
the letter at least crumples it up and
hides it uh and then he goes with them
on this thing called ice dodging but
they're you know there's no glacier so
they go they pretty much do rock dodging
on this boat um in which Angus asked to
help out
and when Sokka shouting the orders he's
like what does that mean what does that
mean so that makes no sense why they
wouldn't go over what things on the ship
do so I mean I know the brother and
sister would know it but you wouldn't
know it so um so they do that and uh you
know in the wonderful you know crowning
of the irony they say you know and
Katara you are bravery Sokka you are I
don't know wisdom or knowledge of
something like that and angular trust
you are the essential focus of trust in
this collection in this group and I'm
like which of course you know you
finally says okay look this I gotta let
you know I kept this from you and any
shows shows them the map and you know
the two kids freaked pretty rightfully
so you know that hey this is the map to
our Father even though they did just
sort of agree that they weren't going to
go to the Father
but nonetheless I can understand their
anger socket in a millisecond just says
we're done and we're done guitar you
coming with me you're with me or against
me
katara gets in the same mindset as just
like I'm coming with you Sokka screw the
avatar and walks off it's like what what
where did all this come from like this
is so strange because everything else in
the show is so well building up and
adding on top of these things
and here's just these sudden really
forced contrived moments that obviously
are going to resolve themselves at the
end of the episode because you haven't
had enough time to build up that this is
something that would last over several
episodes so it felt unbelievably forced
and sure enough even Sokka just like
halfway walking bags like nah we're
wrong we should go back
katara millisecond yeah you're right and
then even bata who at first was like you
know hey you really should think about
this but then we says he's leaving gang
he just joins him and oh he says they're
gonna go back he's like that's the right
thing to do it's even he's switching
sides you know flip-flopping like mad
so all this builds up to you know uh
this but the other thing I forgot to
mention okay so there's also this bounty
hunter who's a pretty cool character uh
she sir rides this giant I want to say
like a dinosaur mole that's who I can
does guy has sort of like a mole nose
and it sees through smell pretty much
and it can track anything so they use
guitars necklace the Fire Nation uses
Katara's necklace to find him and locate
the avatar
uh she was cool though again like just
inconsistent stuff like you know and she
looks like she's dude I don't know like
early 20s or something like that and
this is not you know she's tough but
she's not strong you look her it's like
oh this is not a muscle-bound woman and
yet you see her in this place this bar
where apparently she's like armwrestling
these guys that look like street fighter
contenders I mean just a huge
muscle-bound guys and she's defeating
him over and over it's like how
is this happening they never explained
how that's happening so again maybe
they'll explain later but eight she's is
you know if you're gonna make this woman
like really muscular and tough make her
look muscular and Tom and make her look
like that you know that night friend
Game of Thrones that one woman that's
like a giant it's like yeah okay
if she was armwrestling you get it cuz
like she's huge and she's got the muscle
you know but yeah this woman's like you
know normal size you know not many
months how is she defeating these people
um and that's out that that and goes in
and says oh yeah it's nice to be in a
room that's covered with dead animal
skins you know it fair enough monk you
know but he's not gonna push too hard
but then you see I'm wearing like the
head of one of the animal skins on his
head it's like dude you're uncomfortable
with that for a second so it's all these
inconsistencies it's amazing young
inconsistencies in this episode um but
there's for all that there's two things
I really do like uh one is the climax is
really good again just some great
fighting again really great displaying
that balance there there's a scene where
they're fighting on top of a well you
know you got the hole in the middle and
they're just stepping on the sides of it
now in a cartoon that would not be very
interesting cuz it's a cartoon there's
no they can do whatever they want but
they keep that balance there and and
they sort of shake the camera so it
looks a little bit more like you're
watching it and they show different
angles where the feet are stepping it's
very well choreographed and I get very
nicely done there's this great battle
between Appa and this um whether that
that mole ass or a dinosaur thing you
know if they have a cool little fight
the bounty hunter gets in the fight you
know and the uncle is there you know
just sort of smelling perfumes and stuff
but you got a coup or Zuko and the
Avatar fighting is it's a great fight uh
so that's really cool and it took its
time with the in bells really neat um
the only other thing I really liked in
it was that during the the ice dodging
scene um you got them going towards the
rocks and bottom
says you know okay is a sack are you
proving yourself you don't need to go
any further he says no I think I can do
this you know
Katara use your waterbending and then
use your waterbending you know to raise
the water up see we can get over the
rocks and they just barely make it and
that's it
and I like that because one of the
things I noticed more and more
particularly about American culture and
our ethics and what we like to stress is
that Americans seem to be I mean just by
how we were created we seem very
naturally rebellious and overly
confident we're sort of you know
blissfully naive that we don't know what
can hurt us so we sort of go in
headfirst
um and a lot of American morals try to
stamp against that and rightfully so
again it's it's sort of what we do so we
try to incorporate more teamwork and you
know stand together and don't be so
selfish and so on so forth you know and
you don't need to prove to yourself
everything it's okay to lose sometimes
uh every once in a while it's nice to
get you know a message that says you
know what sometimes a little risk-taking
is okay you know and sometimes it can
pay off again not that we necessarily
need a lot of that message but it's nice
to still know that is a message you can
take risks and they can pay off and they
have to be smart they have to be
calculating osaka did just go into and
say we'll make it you know it's he had a
plan so I like that I mean that's a very
minor thing but I thought that was
pretty cool
um but aside from that yeah I thought
this was like a really weak episode um
it had a good climax I liked that little
thing in the middle there and I like my
the father's alive um and the Bounty
Hunter's cool even though like I said
the whole strength thing doesn't make
sense
um but yeah how many episodes I mean
what episodes that's like I put some 15
and I finally found one I'm like yeah I
don't like that I've been careful that
episode stumped recive I mean we're
getting near the end of the first season
by
come across an episome I didn't like
that one um that that's pretty well done
so that's just naturally gonna happen um
and even though there were good things
in it so uh yeah god we're getting
pretty close to the end of the first
season here Rea we got five more
episodes and then beginning in the
second season so yeah uh hasn't been
stuff just didn't care for the rest of
it so hopefully the next one will be
even better and I will see you at that
next one till then